someone wrote me this they want more
details on Ronnie's wedding with all the
recap of the wedding I'm dying to hear
JD's speech with the reception hey uh
look I listen to JD's speech it's
[__] ridiculous first of all he
Giggles a lot when he gets nervous I
guess he giggles and mumbles you don't
know what the [__] he's talking about I
can play it for you this is JD at the
reception giving a speech they got him
up there and he's clearly just befuddled
and is giggling first of all shout out
to all the Ohio people here tonight
Ohio
especially everyone
uh I don't
know I uh listen I I I love you both I
uh I I I don't like to travel I don't
like to
socialize I don't like to do
anything um but I came here all about
about himself oh hi Ohio people I don't
like to
travel holy [__] worst speech ever I
don't like to travel you're not wrong
there's a minute 16 left on this thing
let me hear what else you give cuz I
support you both and I love you both and
I'm probably not the only one uh you
know you
know i' I've met some so blond like
Woody
Woodpecker no I I I love you both R I
love you too you know what I okay s take
this over s has Workshop so much old man
material that uh I feel that I'm
[Music]
uh I I love them I love them both no I
love them both leave me alone thank you
very much thank leave me alone the last
line of the speech is leave me alone
leave me alone I love you
man I love you
both leave me alone
oh that's what I do I guess I don't know
I love it
man it's like I thought you had prepared
lines and stuff you were going to say
what happened no I kind of had a
prepared thing but you know by the time
I got up there I I was uh a little lit
and uh and you know I just wanted to
you're not wasting now let's hear it it
was basically I wanted to express how
much I cared about you guys uh and the
fact that I uh left the house and this
and that like that sort of feeling and
you know whatever it's can I give you a
tip uhuh when you give a speech you
don't talk about how like you never
leave the house you just talk about your
feelings no that's that's how I felt CU
they are that important to me why don't
you start with this the two of you are
very important to me I listen we're now
we're uh we're Monday morning
quarterbacking I don't know what to tell
you that's okay much better to say five
times I love you both I didn't say it
was that was great either Robin I didn't
say that was great either but why do you
love them why do I love them because uh
I see the love they have for each other
um that's not why you love them well and
they're very nice to me and it's they're
fun to hang out with and how are they
nice to Ronnie uh uh you know is taking
me out on the road and stuff and why
didn't you get up there and say that why
didn't you say listen I want everyone to
know I love Ronnie no one ever wants to
be with me but Ronnie took me out on the
road and Ronnie is gracious with his
time he takes time out of his life to
help people like me yes he's very
generous he's one of the most generous
men I've ever known W there's a word
he's generous there's your speech well
there there you go I just did it now you
never come to me you never say how do I
give a speech I would help you yeah okay
I'll call you right up after the show
you imagine hello help
me